and you've been single for 20 something
you've been in relationship in
relationships yeah but yeah but we you
haven't lacked relationships but you've
seen
how much of it's changed how how
different is it today because i don't
know what it is to swipe right i don't
know what it is to have what do you call
it online access to all these apps that
are out there that makes it a lot easier
believe it or not does that does that
mean a guy's ability to have a
mouthpiece today doesn't matter as much
as it did 15 years ago you know do you
know what i'm asking yeah yeah yeah you
know like back in the days like we have
to go up and and you know say lines
here's what i'll tell you with that yeah
um you guys tell me because i'm yeah
yeah
i'm going to give you guys two totally
different perspectives
i remember being in eighth grade liking
a girl and i had to call up her freaking
landline
the dad picked up the phone
i had to say hello mr so-and-so can i
speak with so and so who's this well
like i have to get through that barrier
okay do you imagine you know the
freaking balls you need to have as a 13
year old boy to get through the dad in
order to speak to the girl
in order to and that's before she even
got on the phone then i got to be able
to spit some game and then get what like
do you understand the barriers to entry
are so ridiculous insanely easy now
you need to have be able to talk you
need to have confidence you have swag
you need to have respect you need to
have just a good head on your shoulders
you need to understand the way today you
do no no back then oh yeah yeah now you
could be a [ __ ] schmuck slide into a
girl's dm with a sup girl you up like
and a girl will respond
like the game that you need to have back
then is so much stronger than it is
today now with that being said
it's so much easier now you can go on
any different app you can go on
instagram you can go on anywhere and you
can start
you know so making your move and the and
the the last thing i'll say is
here's what i will say
what i've learned in my 20 years i've
okay i've been partying in south beach
for 20 years
college after college now in my early
40s
when you're in your 20s you're focused
on your boys
okay the boys want to have a good time
we're going out
in your 30s now all your friends are
getting married you're focusing on the
girls perspective you're putting
yourself in the girl's shoes
the most liberating thing now is being
40 you know when you're and you're like
all right
you focus on yourself and this is
basically what you're talking about
you're not worried about your boy's
opinion you're not worrying about
appeasing any particular female or like
trying to
you know be someone you're not
the the realest thing you could be is is
who you are and be what you want and
then
from there what do you call it hold
frame and say now this is what i look
for this is what i want and if you can't
reach that oh good i don't want to waste
your time the number one thing is not
being able to waste time i'd rather
invest my time than spend time anyway
okay so i'll break it down right because
we're in the game right now and it's
funny because a lot has changed since
you know you were back in the day now as
you know
and my opinion in our opinion is the
biggest thing now in the world is
instagram yep because guess what
celebrities influencers athletes
stars movie stars right guess what those
platforms and girls are actively on
these platforms every single day guess
what i can have a girl in idaho
tennessee i don't know alaska right i
could send a damn say yo kind of miami
guess what first flight out she's in
miami but
here's the problem right back in the day
didn't have that because if you're in
those states or you're in these cities
no one knew who you were when people
around you would actually see you in
real life now because of social media
the climate has changed i could see him
go anywhere in the world and get her
here so picture this right
as easy as the dml you said earlier i
could send it to today and if you're
verified even better because guess what
now you're a valid uh person of i want
to say um status status right so
regarding brand awareness having a brand
and being that guy now on social media
you win so look for example i stutter a
lot right i'm not really the most i want
to say uh talk to this person because
i don't that much but my brand awareness
is on point because
my lifestyle what i do and then for
example just me being a social media
presence guess what that's enough for me
to get what i want as a result this
might be a little controversial i used
to date three or three girls a day so
literally wake up at like um at 8 am go
to work lunch time i'll go on like a
little date and then afterwards i'm
going to do it again and then
at night but guess what over social
media i'll be at home on my instagram
senator damn yo what are you doing
tonight on free cool uh uh link up or
for example hey we do during the day
link up and it's that easy now here's
the problem though right with this much
access and options it's hard to say you
know what damn i'm gonna be with this
girl because she's these these these are
traits because there's so many girls now
you could hit up it's like yo why settle
for one
however i'll say this regarding this
whole lifestyle of being a player all
options
is it fulfilling no because at the end
of the day i've realized from experience
the best thing you can do as a man
is show your time someone you care about
and actually want to be around because
all these girls will yeah you could
smash in whatever have that experience
but in reality speaking how not one
person you connect with physically
spiritually
mentally that's important over
everything but regarding the data
marketplace yeah it's super easy
nowadays all right so i'm very
disappointed that you went that deep
relationships
you got me emotional right now you make
him want to watch a notebook and fall in
love
nah bro
very sweet i was taking some notes on
this so like this is this is kind of
this is this is the
the current dating marketplace right now
at a glimpse right so like
if you got this cup right right so let's
pretend that this is a woman's
validation meter right so it used to be
where a woman had to go outside right to
be able to get attention and or
validation from men right she didn't
have the advent of the smartphone and
all this other stuff she had to go
outside and or put herself in a position
going to nightclubs be social whatever
to get attention from men so men's
attention was not as easy to gain as it
is nowadays right so that cl that when
she walks outside the house the cup is
empty right because now she's got to go
out there and get her ego pulled or
whatever and get it brought up but
nowadays thanks to social media by the
time she steps out the house this cup is
full with validation because she opens
up her instagram she has a bunch of dms
she opens up her dating apps has a bunch
of options and what happens is they
start to have an abundance mindset and i
always say women naturally have an
abundance mindset men have to earn their
abundance mindset so just by a girl
existing looking at her phone whatever
it may be i know girls that will turn on
their tinder i've seen them before on
tick tock as well turn on their tinder
get a bunch of matches not go on and
they want any of them and then just
close it down just to get their
validation and just to get like that
value they feel good about themselves
because women
whether they want to admit or not
they're they have a lot of them have low
self-esteem there's a reason why the
makeup industry is never going to go out
of business why hair salons nail salons
even during a pandemic they were still
in business to some degree because women
understand that their primary agency
comes from the way they look right so
getting attention from men reconfirms in
their mind i'm pretty i can still get a
guy because a woman's value is based on
her beauty i don't care what none of
them save and the strongest most
independent woman is going to wear heels
and makeup and lipstick right so
they had to actually go out to get this
validation nowadays thanks to social
media dating apps whatever women get
this attention to validation without
having to do anything besides be at home
and i did an experiment on this right so
a couple years ago i released a dating
course with my with my buddy and when i
was doing the testing right we used to
tender teach guys how to use tinder
sugar apps whatever it may be when i was
doing the testing to see which uh you
know the best way to get matches and
everything else like that see how the
algorithm goes i had two phones i did an
a b test right so on one phone i
basically did a boost right on all the
accounts on another one i made a fresh
account didn't do no boost right and i
turned the phones off for about 24 hours
turn it back on and both phones have a
bunch of notifications right and i'm
like oh yeah this is [ __ ] awesome
this is great i'm like yeah i'm getting
his attention whoo you know then hit me
imagine getting this amount of attention
every single day for nothing more than
the fact that i'm alive it would
probably make me a piece of [ __ ]
wouldn't it and then i realized like
damn wait hold on this is what a lot of
modern day girls go through every single
day and the studies show it like women
find most men almost over 90 of men on
tinder and bumble these sites as
unattractive below average and
attraction most women don't match worth
and or look at profiles unless the guys
in the top five percent of dudes um one
in three men right now is either a
virgin and or sexually enacted between
18 to 30. so it's become harder for a
majority of men to get girls with the
new social media age because women have
more options than before and a girl that
would have been uh you know constrained
to her own sexual marketplace let's say
she lived in iowa whatever maybe idaho
right she had that area and we talked
about this in deep with royal tomasi it
was a localized sexual marketplace but
now with the internet dating et cetera
she can go and talk to someone in miami
she can go ahead and talk to someone in
l.a and there's a lot of girls flying
out all over the place because now they
have access to men that they would have
never otherwise had so in other words
when they wake up this glass is full
every single day which is why a lot of
guys are invisible to most women right
so and this is because you know dating
apps and instagram in general so what's
basically happened now is that
the top men
right are getting a majority of the
girls
right the majority of girls are chasing
a very small select men and with the
advent of the internet it's become even
more pronounced and women have become
even more selective because
with them getting a validation that they
get on their phones they're like [ __ ]
this i can i i'm getting hit up by
future i'm getting hit by whatever a
girl literally came on our pod and
talked about yeah i banged future and
you just did me and he was gonna give me
a family but it didn't end up happening
but this is this right the rapper yeah
they're wrapping it up on the air
it's on our show okay they know they
know what time it is but like but that's
that's that's the dating marketplace
when average women now mm-hmm right have
access to top-tier guys and that's just
what happened so like a regular one
fresh goes on a date with three girls a
day yeah
he's coming here
so it's basic long story short a lot of
guys are struggling because women have
higher uh higher standards now and male
attention is worth nothing nowadays so
in other words the dating sites made the
rich richer the poor poorer yes yes yes
it's like stimulus interesting yo you
know the scary part got it there's a
darker side to this dark you want me to
go there
yeah
you know what i'm gonna say right
trigger
so
guys nowadays right girl scout have a
boyfriend
a sneaky link guy that they just [ __ ]
and what do you call it a sneaky link
like you know late night hit him up
sneaky link i'll come over and would you
smash and then you go back home to your
boyfriend whatever is what it is and
then the third one they might have the
trigger daddy so the whole culture now
is okay cool how do i get these things
in life without working for it for girls
and what's the best way trigger daddy i
just show up look pretty
i might [ __ ] or not but i'm gonna get my
rent paid i'm gonna get either a new car
or i might get money to go shopping or
just have fun and think about it right
who are sugar babies nowadays girls in
college i have no money it could be even
a boss baby that just wants a better man
and it's funny because a lot of girls
will say i won't be caught down on
tinder bumble because that's below me
but i'll be on the trigger site waiting
to find a right i gotta take care of me
and as a result guess what now for that
experience they expect all men to be on
a level so the average girl that you see
you're not you're going next door right
you know she's cute pretty she's very to
herself whatever you don't know she
might have two sugar daddies now paying
for her lifestyle you can talk to her
hey suzy i want to take you out
[ __ ] who are you because guess what
you're not on his level and as a result
it's good no because once again social
media it could be a guy under that high
profile it could be a trigger daddy you
never know who you're competing with so
we say for most guys
on some level become the best version of
yourself because at that point you could
kind of play the game but even then you
may not because either they're
millionaires they're sugar daddies you
never really know so as a result most
men will never get the option or even
the chance to play the game of the
dating and the scary part is a lot of
guys don't even know what they're up
against in in the current dating
marketplaces to like why it's so
competitive so what i've always said
like feminism what it's inadvertently
done it's it's actually given all the
leverage to the top five percent of men
yeah because what happens is a woman
earns a gets her own career makes more
money becomes successful well now a
large pool of candidates that would have
been a great husband and a potential
boyfriend this guy doesn't mean
they want to date their equals exactly
right so women we know women on a bounce
probabilities do not date below their
socioeconomic status they want to take
at least bare minimum where they're at
or preferably above so as women make
more money and become more successful
now their pool of men drops down with it
and they want to date up so it's given
the leverage inadvertently to a lot of
the the higher status these women that
that fresh was talking about um how does
it affect their psychic because you said
something very profound earlier you said
you know fast money comes slow problems
yeah so break down that mindset
um so a lot of so there's a lot of women
out there they're like i'm independent i
don't need no man i get my own money the
boss [ __ ] thing yeah it's like
okay how are you getting that money so a
lot of you're a career woman a but maybe
you're more that sugar daddy with three
boyfriends type yeah and i don't think
guys understand like if you see a bad
chick on instagram or she's very
attractive you best believe bro that
she's getting crazy off her she's
getting rapper center up sugar daddy's
whatever it may be like i always tell
guys if you guys really want to see the
dating marketplace if your friends don't
buy a hot chick ask us here instagram
and look at her dms you guys are going
to see what i'm talking about or look at
her dating inbox or her dating profile
inbox or whatever slice she has a lot of
girls live a double life where they're
whether they're on only fans they're
selling feed pictures they're on
snapchat premium they have a sugar daddy
they're getting flown out by a certain
guy or whatever a lot of attractive
women have this thing going on they're
obviously not going to have are they all
ending up in dubai exactly what i'm
saying or it's a chick that's like you
know like what the hell you you were
you're ra at the st school how are you
in [ __ ] ireland right now and then
going to dubai after like so a lot of
girls live this double life thanks to
internet whatever it may be so i always
say you know um fast money comes with
slow problems a lot of girls that do you
know they're strippers only fans
whatever they'll make this money up
front or sell fee picks or whatever
they'll make this money upfront but what
they don't realize is that's going to
have dire consequences on them in the
future when it comes to marriage and or
some kind of stable relationship because
we know how men are men are very
territorial women if you are about a
married chick and she's your girl and
you find out that she did some fuckshit
in the past you're more than likely
going to call off the wedding because
men have a serious point of issue with a
woman's past i always say women want a
man with a future a man wants a woman
that doesn't have a past and that's just
the way it's always been the beginning
of time they're very territorial so a
lot of girls what they don't realize is
they're doing this stuff right and they
kind of know subconsciously is going to
mess me up in the future but if it ever
comes out they don't care it's going to
mess with them and some don't even care
they're just like i'm just going to be a
daddy i don't care except me how i come
but fast money a lot of time does come
with slow problems which is going to be
being able to find a guy and we know a
big predicate on female happiness and
fulfillment typically comes from a
family and children not necessarily a
career making money if you enjoyed this
short clip click over here to watch
another short clip and if you want to
watch the entire episode the entire
podcast click here
[Music]